de nouvelles émeutes sanglantes en
roumanie selon plusieurs sources
concordantes des dizaines de milliers de
personnes sont descendues cet après-midi
dans les rues de bucarest pour scander
des slogans hostiles au régime du
président sait où c'est secouer la
police aurait tiré sur les manifestants
aucune image hormis celle de la
propagande officielle ne franchit pour
l'instant la frontière roumaine et aucun
journaliste étranger n'a pu entrer dans
ce pays notre confrère philippe pecoul
est en direct de la frontière roumano
hongroise philippe vous recueillez tous
les témoignages à la frontière de ceux
qui ont pu s'échapper qui était à
bucarest aujourd'hui quelles
informations avez vous sur la situation
en ville l'opposition notamment
d'hélicoptères
on entendu des cris liberté liberté des
latéraux militaires que des secousses et
exprimer cet après midi à bucarest
devant des dizaines de milliers de
personnes apparemment favorables au
pouvoir il a été interrompu alors que
s'est il donc passé pour promettre de
l'argent et à les garder l'enfant
pourrait bien que ses potes d'améliorer
leurs conditions de vie et bien pas
vraiment il y avait une foule rassemblée
place bellecour pour redevenir
conventionnel
ce décret est pris par les badauds
m'intéresse avec des maîtres dont l'un
est en train d'écouter votre vétérinaire
et romain hissel hôtel qu un autre près
de la frontière
à combien se trouvaient pas ce que c'est
la première fois dans des notes comme
elle disait quelque chose ne va pas
quelque chose
effectivement les offenses et on
comprend dès lors la norme et on parle
de mouvements de ralliement avec les
manifestants qu'en est il exactement
la comprendre et la compléter dans sa
dignité se sont ralliés la population
même dire que telle ou telle violence
sur la population pour le métro gambetta
la concurrence reste hormis le coup et
souhaiterait philippe pecoul je rappelle
que l'été donc en direct de la frontière
roumano hongroise et vous nous rappelez
bien sûr si vous avez de nouvelles
informations d'ici la fin de cette
édition notre invité ni china